near disaster a couple times  but still no turnover shot clock at five  [Music]  the key to stapling a shot blocker to  the ground is get into him well the  thing was  his defender fell down and he was first  one to get up  so he's like i'm just gonna cut to the  rim  and there was javale mcgee  in his way  oh my goodness this is where he fell  down he's like you know what my guy's  down i gotta get up bridges is down just  cut to the rim draymond green is going  to see you he cocked it back  [Music]  and just punished javale  bodied  this is as bad as it gets that is  a poster  that i want in my room  yo  the free arm  got javale mcgee in the face  and so javale couldn't elevate to get  there look at the bench the benchmarks  have no idea what to do  damien lee can't stand